Oh my gosh.
I hope... oh my god I'm so fucking glad it's over.
That was so nervous and that karaoke... it's always the first karaoke.
It's always the first karaoke like I'm so nervous about because like you know I don't know how it's gonna go.
And I'm like oh scum I can't believe... I can't believe I kept crashing in the beginning and then I had to fix it live.
I was like no!
I'm really happy you guys liked it.
I did get like the copyright stuff but it was just like oh you can't monetize it and I was like fine that's fine.
I'm okay with not monetizing it.
I'm okay.
I can keep it up.
It just says like oh you just... you just...
can't monetize it.
I was like I'm fine with that.
I'm... it's alright.
That's why we have an after party here.
And like oh my god I was like re-listening to it.
Are you guys sure the instrumental was okay?
I was worried the instrumental was too loud.
Was it alright?
Was the instrumental too loud or was it okay?
I was really... I was really really worried it was too loud.
I was like re-listening to it.
I was like oh my god is this too loud?
Can you guys hear me okay?
It sounded great?
Really?
It was fine.
Okay I trust you guys.
It was great.
I trust you guys.
Oh my god.
I was like really... I was really nervous that the instrumental was like too loud for like too loud compared to me.
So I was like oh thank god.
Okay you guys felt like it was okay.
And I realized I actually forgot one song.
I forgot to sing one song that I actually really wanted to like do like as a little bonus because...
But then I was like you know.
I was like oh man I was so busy.
You know what?
Maybe this... this video might not be...
This stream might not be monetized too.
I didn't get to use the bathroom.
Okay guys I need to use the bathroom.
Because I was like just like re-watching everything.
Okay guys I'm sorry I'm scuffed.
I'm... I'm even scuffed now.
I didn't use the bathroom.
I didn't get to use the bathroom.
I am
back.
I'm back here.
Oh my god.
I came back and there was... Oh my... Alex thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I came back and there was like 50 gift... Oh my god.
Thank you Alex.
I really appreciate it.
I was so nervous because like you know it was like... First karaoke is always like the most nerve-wracking part.
And I was like I... I like wish I did more practice.
I definitely wish I did practice a little bit more on the singing.
But like there was so many things going on and I was like so busy that I didn't get a chance to practice as much as I would love to.
So I was like stumbling my words.
I was like... I was stumbling my words a lot.
And... I don't know why I can't breathe now.
Now I can't even breathe.
I don't know why.
Cypher thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm here on time this time.
Totally did not oversleep.
You did great Doki here.
Here I hope the scuff doesn't get you down and down.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Cypher.
I'm... I hope... Yeah I'm glad you guys enjoyed the scuff.
I was like no I'm quashing.
No.
Oh my god.
I was like in the beginning I was like really?
And I realized it was because of the program.
I was using the web browser version of KaraFun instead of the... I was using a web version instead of like the program itself.
I forgot because like it's been so long since I did the karaoke that I forgot to use the actual program instead of the web browser.
Because the web browser version overloads my PC because it's like really fucking... the processing for it is like huge and stuff.
So I forgot about that and I was like trying to figure out.
I was like oh my gosh what do I do?
And I was like oh my god maybe if I use the program.
And then the moment I used the program it stopped.
It stopped.
Oh my god.
And then like... but then after that it was okay.
I can't believe... I had to like redo several songs.
But if you guys didn't hear at 800k subscribers it will be my next karaoke.
I will do my next karaoke at 800k subscribers.
And then I will tell you guys the production value for... the production value and everything will be bigger and better than the one that we have.
I will... I blame Canada 100%.
The amount...
I sang blame Canada five fucking times... four... it was four fucking times.
That's how much hate I have.
It's always good.
It's Canada's fault.
Like now thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not VTB stream without technical difficulties.
It's true.
Thank you for the super chat.
Yeah but I'm such a perfectionist.
I made you guys... I felt really bad.
Because I made you guys wait 40 minutes too.
And I was like nooo.
You guys waited 40 minutes.
YouTube.
Canada and OBS.
Hahaha.
All of the above.
Everything.
It's not just it's never my fault.
It's everything.
But yeah anyway.
So that was... that was fun.
Trying to fucking navigate that.
I was like...
It's okay.
Even though... even though I've been streaming for like...
Even though I've been streaming for like... what is it?
Three... four years... four plus years now.
Oh actually no.
Like more so like professionally.
Like before that I wasn't like actually professionally streaming.
But like even though I've been streaming professionally for like two plus years.
I... I...
I hope I'm getting better at streaming.
I...
Hahaha.
I... I...
I hope I'm getting better at being a streamer.
And like... and like...
The scuf is not as bad.
Hahaha.
Like I hope the scuf was not... didn't turn off.
And the reason why I'm always like really worried about like scufed.
Is that like...
Um...
Is like I'm worried that that's...
Like you know...
Like basically turned off fans and stuff.
I'm like, why can't I fucking control this?
I'm like, why can't I control this?
I like having control over what's going on on my stream.
I'm like...
I hope you guys still had fun and enjoyed it.
The crashing was a little...
The crashing was like...
It was a lot of fun though.
Like I said, at 800k subscribers...
It's gonna be a bigger production value.
Maybe some custom outfits, you know?
Not like custom VTuber...
Not like custom like skin suit outfit.
But you know, like...
You remember like last time...
How big the production was last time?
Maybe something similar, you know?
Hehehehe...
Maybe something similar like that.
Honestly, it was so...
So big brain.
It was really fucking big brain of me.
But it's like...
To have like...
To edit...
And edited video and stuff...
To play over it.
Versus like...
Okay, in the past, I usually...
Like...
Manual...
I...
Manual stuff where I like press buttons manually on my stream deck...
To like...
The performance, you know?
Like I have like random stuff.
Jumping in and out and stuff like that.
So I would do that manually on my stream deck.
I still did some today manually...
Ow...
On my stream deck...
But like...
I was like, you know what?
Bro, this could be even better if I had an editor do this.
So I was like, at my editors, I was like, who wants to try it out?
And then Shad, who is one of my editors for my shorts, was like, I can't.
And then our first video we did was Welcome to the Internet.
And it was so good.
And then today I woke... okay, to be fair, I didn't wake up.
It was more like I... after the JP tournament, I messaged him.
And I was like, oh my god, can you also do like Blame Canada and Friends Like Me before the stream?
And he's like, this is cutting it real close, but I'm gonna try.
And like, bro, that guy fucking cried.
Like, he like fucking did it.
He like, he got what I wanted in there because I was explaining like my vision.
And then he actually did it before the stream.
To be fair, I did push the stream 40 minutes.
Like, we did push the stream 40 minutes.
But like, it was worth it.
I felt like the wait was worth it, guys.
I felt like the wait was so fucking worth it for like what we had.
Hey, Gio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
A true dragoon stays because their scuff is part of the charm.
And in no way made the experience bad.
I love your karaoke, though.
Can you sing despite what you sing?
It's really good.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat, Gio.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm really, really happy.
Uh, uh, that you guys really, uh, really liked it.
And I'm, I'm super happy.
Because like, you know, I was experimenting with this idea.
You know, the, the experimentation of the idea of having a video playing over it during karaoke.
And then it makes the karaoke much more fun.
Um, because like, you know, I don't like doing just something simple.
I like to pizzazz it a bit more.
Like, you know, like, I know, like, I'm not the best singer.
Like, I know, like, I was just like, no, don't give me love hearing you sing.
But come on.
I know I'm not the best singer.
Okay.
We don't need a lie to ourselves.
I might not be the best fucking singer.
So like, um, I try my best to like, you know, make it, my karaoke is just a little bit more special.
With like, what you see.
So like, it's literally like a performance, you know?
Like, um, um, like a performance.
And, uh, just like have fun with it and stuff like that.
And, you know, like, just have like a fun time.
Like we were watching it's like a fun time.
Um, and I did have a lot of fun.
Like, uh, the, um, soup.
Honestly, I know I'm like fucking patting myself on the back, but super big brain of me to have like, like edited videos instead of doing the fucking props and assets stuff.
Uh, like by hand, actually super big brain.
Super.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Thanks for the karaoke stream, Doki.
Everything stays the same.
Sometimes even the scuff.
It was Katniss' fault for the technical difficulties.
Keep being me.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
I think the one funny part was the fact that like, you know, the, uh, the, the sequel, like just ended.
I was not ready for that.
I was like, wait, that's it.
Cause I like listened to the song, but I never listened to the, all the way through.
It's the end.
I was just like, wait, it just ended.
I was like, okay, that's, that's it.
But honestly, like I felt like that song was like, yeah, that's me.
We're doing a sequel.
But a better dad.
We're going to do it all over again.
We're doing a sequel.
We're back by popular demand.
Come on, everybody.
Strike.
Up the band.
And like everybody knows, sequel's never quite as good.
I definitely had a lot of fun.
Rockstar, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
It was really fun.
I'm glad.
I'm glad you guys had a lot of fun.
There was like a song that I did forgot to do.
I mean, I could, okay, guys.
All right.
I'll give you guys my treat.
Give me a sec.
I'm going to disappear a little bit.
My treat guys.
This is the right one.
I'm gone for a little bit, but don't worry.
I promise you guys.
I was like, okay, I was going to do this as like a bonus.
And then like, I forgot about it, but I know like a lot of people demanded it.
I saw so many people asking for this.
So I was like, whoops.
Okay.
This, this stream might not be monetized as well.
I might get like, striked.
I don't know how to sing this song.
I never practiced it.
It's been like so long, but I saw so many people were like, oh my God, please sing this.
Okay.
What is it called again?
Oh, okay.
Here.
I think it's this.
Okay.
I'm just gonna have the video play with me too.
Cause I actually, I actually don't remember this, how to sing this song.
I just know how to sing like the beginning part.
I need to tell you guys, I actually don't remember.
I was singing this song.
Here we go.
Okay.
Yeah.
Wait.
Reverb.
All right.
Here we go.
That's all I remember.
Okay.
I don't remember how to sing this part.
Oh my God.
He sings it so fast.
I can't read it out.
I can't read this in time.
All right.
They sing it too fast.
I can't read it in time.
All right.
I'm not gonna read this one.
Never mind.
Alright.
This is so funny clay.
All right.
Really.
Look at the face.
Yeah.
I can't believe it.
I really can't read this one.
From stumbling.
It never changed.
She is never changed.
And that's like... I can't.
I stumble so much.
That's the only part I can actually sing.
There you go guys.
Here's the meow song.
It's called Learn to Meow.
It's a good song.
That song was stuck in my head for so fucking long when I first heard it.
But even then, I could never do more than that.
I can only do the first chorus.
That's it.
The BGM is... No, it's too late.
I guess this VOD won't be monetized as well.
How about...
That was honestly the only... I only remember how to sing the first.
Because I can't read fast enough.
Even with the pinyum.
With the pinyum, I was trying to read it.
But they sing it so fast that my brain was just like...
I really can't read the pinyum fast enough.
Like the cool kids.
I can't.
I'm so bad at it.
I can barely read English.
Let alone Chinese right now.
I'm too fucking stupid, man.
Zecra and Ivy, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Bless.
Namo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Meow.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yes, I think this stream is definitely going to get demonetized.
Because I literally played the song in the background.
LOL LOL
I turned off my reverb.
But yes, guys.
800k subscribers.
Remember, like and comment and subscribe.
I feel like an actual YouTuber now.
Like and comment and subscribe.
If you love this video and the karaoke, remember to like, comment and subscribe.
So I don't know... You know like people will be like...
Oh, if this video hits 500k likes, I will do blah blah blah.
It's not going to be doing.
If my karaoke bot hits 100k likes and we hit 800k subscribers, we're going to do another karaoke.
It still does.
It's so... Like, do people still do this?
Yeah, because of the fucking YouTube algorithm.
Yeah, the call to action.
It's the smash that like button and hit the notification bell.
It's the YouTube algorithm.
People are desperate.
I'm desperate.
People?
Me.
I'm people.
Also like, by the way guys.
Yeah, like karaoke stuff.
Like I've been like planning it on and off.
I wish I did have more time to plan the karaoke.
I feel like I did sort of rush into the karaoke a little bit.
But I really wanted to have the karaoke like last week.
Because you know, I promised you guys a karaoke before the chari...
Like before the month was over.
For March.
But then obviously like stuff happened in the schedule.
So I had to put it.
But I didn't want to delay it too much.
Because the charity goal was...
The charity goal was like...
Oh, I will have the karaoke before March was over.
So then I was like, okay, alright.
We're going to fucking do this.
We're going to do it.
Because I do wish I did have more time to plan for it.
Due to how busy I've been behind the scenes.
But I did learn a lot.
I'm going to... I did learn a lot.
Regarding planning the charity stuff.
So...
Not charity stuff.
Regarding planning this karaoke.
Because it's been a lot of times since I've done karaoke.
And done like sang stuff like this.
So...
I still...
I did that...
Did it because...
I tried to make sure I was able to do it.
Just because I wanted to...
To...
You know...
Make up for the chari...
Like actually follow through on the charity goal stuff.
And...
So yeah.
But the real karaoke.
The real super karaoke.
With...
It was just beta.
We're beta testing chat.
That was a beta test.
To the actual karaoke.
Which would be the 800k subscriber one.
Like...
We were beta testing.
You know?
Like the...
The...
What is...
What is it called?
The...
Pilot episode.
Karaoke pilot episode.
The karaoke was a pilot episode.
For the real karaoke.
That's why it was so scum.
You know?
We're looking for...
We're looking for investors.
To fund the pilot karaoke.
You know?
You know how like...
Gravity Falls.
The pilot episode for Gravity Falls.
And like Bob's Burgers.
Like all of that.
You could tell it was...
It's like not as great.
You know?
It's not that good.
That was the karaoke.
It was a pilot episode.
We're just looking for investors.
We're looking for somebody to fund our future karaoke's.
Um...
I'm sorry.
Can we get VeggieTales theme next karaoke stream?
And so you'll think of a super chat.
It might be funny as the main voice is a tomato.
VeggieTales.
Broccoli.
That's a pilot.
There you go.
Here's your pilot episode.
Uh...
Subscribe to fund for the...
Subscribe to fund...
Subscribe and invest to fund for the real karaoke guys.
Subscribe.
Oh shit...
You only get a little bit before the act...
Before the actual karaoke.
Um...
Also, we're like, not gonna lie.
Tomorrow we don't...
I don't know how long tomorrow is going to be because it's heavily dependent on...
It's going to be heavy...
Tomorrow is going to be heavily dependent on like how lucky we are when it comes to like if there's shitty teams...
If there is shitty teams that's going to be participating.
We're celebrating the Apex Legends Challenges circuit and stuff like that.
So like, the thing is we didn't practice.
Wig, Tenpo and I have not had a single practice session together.
I talked about this yesterday on the JP tournament thing.
But like, Wig fucking... apparently like...
He passed out yesterday and never checked his internet.
Like, never checked his socials or like his text messages.
Because we were trying to fucking... we're like, we're izzy.
Because we were supposed to have a practice session yesterday off stream.
And I was gonna be off stream.
And then today, this morning, he messaged us and was like, sorry, I was so fucked up, man.
I was like, guys, are we gonna be okay?
I was like, Tenpo was like, there's no way we're gonna be okay.
We're gonna lose the first round.
There's like golden plat players in there.
And I'm like...
And then Wig was like, but it would be so fucking funny though.
And I'll be like, but I get to end this early.
Now you reached last.
We were like, but it would be so fucking funny.
And I'm like, yeah, it was so funny.
I get to leave early.
So...
Next week...
We're gonna have two...
You know how we're like, oh, we're gonna have one content warning.
We're gonna have two content warning streams.
So I hope you guys won't be too tired for the content warning stuff.
Because next week, we have two content warning streams with two different groups.
The first group will be like...
Will be...
JP slash...
Chinese centric.
So like...
I'm collabing with...
The first content warning stream...
Will be with...
Ditto, Hiro...
H-I-I-R-O.
Hiro from...
And...
You might recognize her name actually, Hiro.
Who was it?
Another one.
Na-chan.
So Hiro and Na-chan are from...
Billy Billy.
And then, you know, Ditto and I are...
YouTube Twitch.
So like...
It's gonna be like...
Fun trying to like...
Communicate with everybody.
So...
That's gonna be the first content warning stream.
And then the second content warning stream will be with...
It's gonna be with...
Snuffy...
Lime...
And Han.
Hanbyul.
So that's the...
That's the second...
Content warning stream.
One is gonna be on Friday.
And I think one is on Thursday.
And the other one is on...
The first one will be on Thursday.
The second one will be on Saturday.
So...
That is the...
The double content warning stream.
That's gonna be the collabs for...
Next week.
That's gonna be the...
Collab...
Two collabs...
Cause you know...
I usually schedule...
One to two collabs...
Per...
Per week.
And that's gonna...
I know I actually...
Put two content warning streams.
But I was just like...
You know what?
I wanna be able to play with all the different people.
You know?
I wanna be able to...
Hang out with...
A bunch of different people next week.
So I set up two...
Two content warning streams.
Um...
I don't know.
I don't know what to say.
What else?
Okay.
Shout out Colossus.
Also next week...
We're gonna...
I...
Can I say bring back?
I guess...
I...
I mean...
I guess...
Shout out Colossus.
For members...
I'm bringing back the...
Commissions are open.
I'm gonna draw your icon horribly.
But if you've like commissioned me before...
Um...
The...
Draw your icon horribly.
If you could like...
Let me know.
Like...
Tell me what you... let me know.
Like, I'm gonna make a members post and just...
Just tell me if you commissioned me before it still stands.
Because if I haven't drawn your icon yet, it still stands.
Like...
Obviously, I don't have access to like the archive of it anymore.
But like, if you commissioned me for an icon...
And you're from the... from before.
The before four times.
Don't worry, in the members post, just fucking...
Like...
Like, find a way to let me know.
We're gonna do honor system.
Because I know you dragoons have honor, right?
You guys... you guys have honor, right?
We're doing a sequel.
I just so have...
We're back by popular demand.
We're doing a sequel.
Da da da da da da.
Ba ba da ba da ba da ba ba ba ba ba ba ba.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Um...
Yeah, anyway.
So, I'm bringing that back next week.
If you haven't got an icon for me.
And I'll keep it open for future... for new dragoons too.
So, uh... for new dragoons as well.
If you guys want an icon.
Um... it will be open for that as well.
Um...
Let's see.
What else?
What else do I want to update you guys on?
I think that's like majority of my updates.
I think like next week is a bit more chill.
Because of the fact that... uh...
Uh... I'm not doing as much next week.
It's just collabs.
There's not really any events or stuff I'm participating in.
Or anything.
I still can't believe Twitch asked me to headline a Roblox Twitch Rivals.
I think that's like the funniest shit ever.
I thought that was so...
I thought that was like...
So fucking funny that...
That like... Twitch was like...
Do you wanna... Do you wanna like... be the headline for Roblox?
And I was like... Bro, that's so fucking funny.
I'm down.
I'm so... I'm so fucking... I'm so fucking down.
Also... um...
Bro, I'm having the worst time with customs.
Like I told you guys... Like I know all of you guys are like...
Oh my god, PC fun.
Doki, PC fun.
Like... I'm supposed to have...
Customs been holding my PC, man.
I was like... Oh my god!
Yay!
PC!
I was gonna be like so hyped.
Cause I'll be like...
Guys!
Finally!
After you complained about my PC!
My new PC!
It's been stuck in customs.
Please!
I... I checked the track.
I checked the tracking every fucking day.
And it's still in the goddamn warehouse.
Like release my PC!
Every day I check the fucking customs!
So yes, the reason why my PC is still fucked up...
Is because... um...
Is because, you know...
They... they're... I'm waiting.
I'm wait... Don't worry guys.
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting just like all of you.
Fucking Canada, man.
Oh!
Also...
I wanted to talk about this.
But like...
Did you guys know you can cheese gacha now?
I did not realize this at all.
But apparently like...
People have figured out...
You can cheese like...
Not like digital gacha.
But like linebox gacha.
You know like those like merch...
Like figure gacha.
Um... I wanna give you guys a shout out.
I'm gonna give you guys a little life hack.
And like...
So like if you wanna get a blind box...
Or like a figure or anything...
If you look underneath the...
If you look at the box's serial numbers...
It's like...
Uh... different numbers and stuff.
So like...
The serial numbers underneath...
Or like any numbers that's on a box...
Or like any on the like blind box and stuff...
Correlates to specific figure.
Or like a specific items.
So like...
You don't have to...
It's not random.
It's actually not random.
Hahaha!
I think I've...
I learned that on a YouTube short.
I learned that from YouTube shorts guys.
Uh...
But like basically...
If you...
So you don't get...
You don't have to be blind.
You don't have to...
It won't be blind anymore.
It's real!
It's actually real!
If you want to do...
If you...
If you want to like do like IRL gacha...
Or like figure gacha and stuff like that...
Or like blind boxes...
All the stuff...
Like all the code...
There's like...
Just like the codes correlate to the figure.
So like if you don't want...
You're worried you're gonna get like duplicate...
If you're worried you're getting duplicate...
You can like just like look at the boxes underneath...
And then like just make sure it's just the different numbers...
So you don't have to...
You won't get like a double...
Double blind box.
Um...
Will there be any more questions?
Will there be a discord server for the dragoons to hang out with each other and get Doki scuf updates on the PC customs in the future?
McDowell!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I mean there's unofficial discord...
Uh...
I just need you guys...
Regarding discords...
I know like a lot of people are always asking me like...
Oh Doki when will you ever have like a discord server?
Um...
I'm never going to have an official discord server.
I know this is like a really a twitch thing...
But like my substitute for a discord server is like YouTube members.
Um...
The reason why I don't have a discord server is because like I learned...
When you have...
When you have like...
Okay like...
Uh...
I know like when I first started when I was like you know four years ago I did have my own discord server four years ago.
But I was like really small.
I was a really small streamer and I was on twitch.
I got...
I was on twitch so...
Um...
Like it's more known for like twitch streamers to have discord servers.
But the reason why I don't do that...
I don't do that now...
Um...
I use my member stream as like the equivalent of a discord server with the things I do on members.
So I do post like updates.
I do post updates.
I do post like um...
Um...
Like...
Uh...
You know like I do like exclusive streams on members and stuff like that.
But the reason why is that um...
I think like a year ago um...
I joined some...
I think like a year and a half ago I joined somebody's like official server.
Like uh...
For a collab.
I think like you guys might remember this.
This is like old lore.
Um...
And then I got so many random people messaging me and sending me friend requests uh...
To that account.
And like I was like wait this is not smart for...
That's why I don't...
I don't want to have...
I don't do official discord servers.
Because like it's just gonna mess up my discord even more.
I...
I get like...
Every day I wake up to like um...
Uh...
Every day I wake up to like 16 plus work messages every day from like different people.
And I really cannot have that get cleared.
I hate...
I...
Like I really cannot like have more messages and friend requests.
It's also...
The reason why also is cause like my friend...
Like um...
I also like don't really uh...
Uh...
Close my friend requests and stuff.
Um...
Or like not close.
I...
I make sure my...
My friend requests...
Like it's still like private in some way for friend requests.
But like it's not like super close.
Because like um...
When I...
I do like work business stuff.
Like behind the scenes work stuff.
I just be like just add me.
I'll just be like just add me.
Because it's just easier.
And I need to be sure that like uh...
Uh...
I just need to be sure that my communication with like people when it comes to business things would be okay.
When I separate account cause logging on and off for two.
I...
I don't...
I don't like dealing with...
I mean I used to deal with more than one account.
But like it's just simpler with everything in one area for me.
Because I already have a lot of stuff going on.
That's why...
That's why I don't have an official server.
An official Discord server.
Because a lot of my communication with work stuff and business stuff is on Discord.
I don't have a Slack or anything anymore.
So it's mostly on Discord and email.
So it's just so much easier just not being on an official server.
But we do have fan servers.
We do have fan servers though.
So if you guys still want to join a Doki Bird fan server, that's still...
They do a lot of projects.
I know they do a lot of projects.
They did a Stinger project recently.
But on April Fools.
I was just so busy that I haven't retweeted it or added my Stingers.
But it's so cute!
Did you guys see it?
They did like a Stinger project.
Oh my god.
Let me see if I can look it up.
I'm trying to remember what it was called.
Okay, Stinger...
Stinger...
Dragoon.
Is that it?
Stinger... Dragoon...
Okay, Doki Bird.
Maybe that's it.
I'm pretty sure my fucking mods will find this faster than me.
I found it!
Guys, it's so cute!
Wait, is this an introduction on how...
This is a guide on how to do it.
Guys, look at this.
Okay, never mind.
My mod did it.
I'm going to do it.
Nice.
My mod did the job for me.
Yay!
Don't worry.
Next stream...
No, not next stream.
The stream after next stream.
Because I'm too fucking...
The next stream is like Challenger Circuit.
So like, I really don't think I have the energy to add...
To add the Stinger by then.
Oh my god.
I really don't have the energy.
I'm really excited.
There's so many stuff going on.
Every... every day.
There's a lot of like...
Events...
That are like... being planned.
There's a lot of...
There's a lot of collaborations.
There's also a lot of like...
Business deals and stuff being planned.
And everything.
And I'm so excited when...
It all...
Finally goes... like...
When things start going live.
I'm super excited.
I wish I could do more projects for you dragoons too.
Like just...
Just solely for you dragoons type deal.
Like... like... in the past.
And obviously a lot of those take time.
Because I need to build like the infrastructure for everything.
And like building the infrastructure for everything.
And building a lot of stuff.
For...
To like be able to create new content.
And create like new things for dragoons.
And it's...
It's taking time.
It takes time.
But what are you guys looking forward to?
Like what would you guys like to see?
Or like to have?
Like...
The Minecraft server for members.
They said it'll take a few more weeks.
Few more weeks to do.
So...
And...
It's just like...
We just...
It just takes time.
It takes a lot of time.
To build everything up.
Oh my gosh.
My energy is slowly dying.
I think my adrenaline is wearing off.
My...
My adrenaline...
Is like...
Is like slowly fucking wearing off.
After...
After everything.
I'm just super chill now.
Uh...
Hahaha.
Everything's shutting down.
I think it's because I didn't get a lot of sleep.
I didn't get a lot of sleep.
I took a nap before the JP Tournament.
And then I had to work a little bit.
And then I took another nap again.
And then...
And then after that nap.
I stayed up too.
I worked for like four hours straight.
For the karaoke stuff.
Like the last minute prep for the...
My pilot...
My pilot test for the karaoke.
Haha.
I'm trying...
But anyway, this is a short after party.
It's a really short after party, I apologize.
But I realize I'm crashing right now.
I'm crashing.
At this point I'm like, oh no.
I'm feeling the crash.
Doki's feeling the crash right now.
She's sinking.
But thank you everybody.
I really enjoyed hanging out with all you guys today.
And I really enjoyed having that fun karaoke session with everybody.
And I hope you guys enjoyed the work everyone put into it.
And I hope you enjoyed the fucking scuff too.
The enormous amount of scuff there.
But you guys all have fun and that's all that matters.
I'm gonna go pass out.
I'm gonna eat dinner and pass out.
So...
I wanted to have a longer chat up with all of you.
But I think I'm actually...
My energy level is like skydiving right now.
It's actually going through...
It's actually nose diving.
But thank you all.
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because we all deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.